[Musique]
merci François Noë buffet mais vous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes sénateur les
républicains du rô président de la
commission des Lois du Sénat vous étiez
donc membres de cette commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi
immigration on va bien sûr en parler
d'abord la loi immigration a donc été
adoptée hier par le Parlement après un
vote du Sénat puis de l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que ce matin vous êtes
soulagé en tous les cas soulagé c'est un
grand mot euh le texte a été adopté il
sera peut-être il sera évidemment déféré
au Conseil constitutionnel mais il va
être promulgué dans quelques temps et
c'est une avancée considérable en
réalité je crois que pour la première
fois depuis de nombreuses années nous
avons essayé de mettre en place à
travers ce texteun politique cohérente
d'immigration avec une stratégie la
difficulté d'aujourd'hui c'est que nous
sommes sur des scénarios au fil de l'eau
et là on a mis on a mis en place une
stratégie quelle est cette stratégie
elle est très simple elle répond à trois
objectifs le premier maîtriser
lesmigration régulière euh c'est-à-dire
réduire en volume le nombre de personnes
qui arrivent sur le territoire fixer des
conditions de respect des valeurs de la
République des conditions naturellement
parfois de ressources bien sûr mais
aussi la volonté de de de de choisir
l'immigration plutôt économique et
plutôt qualifiée et moins les autres
types d'immigration pourquoi parce que
notre pays a besoin de l'immigration ça
c'est incontestable et notamment de
l'immigration qualifié nous le disons le
CDE le dit depuis longtemps c'est très
important et il faut des conditions pour
cela et puis le deuxème point c'est de
traiter d'immigration irrégulière qui
est le le point faible pour ne pas dire
très faible de notre pays et là il faut
être très ferme c'est tolérance zéro
donc on a mis en place tous les
dispositifs qui permettent à l'exécutif
au gouvernement de pouvoir renvoyer les
personnes en situation irrégulière dans
leur pays d'origine ça paraît clair et
puis on oublie souvent c'est aussi tout
le sujet de la demande d'asile il faut
protéger cette procédure elle est en
olisé par les réseaux qui l'utilisent à
d'autres fins et elle du coup elle met
en difficulté ceux qui méritent la
protection et la rapidité de la décision
donc c'est ça la stratégie globale
ensuite évidemment il y a des mesures
particulières on a simplifié les
procédures les procédures à la fois
d'accueil c'est-à-dire que un étranger
qui vient sur le territoire national
aujourd'hui avec le texte il sera vu par
les services de la préfecture sa
situation sera étudiée en globalité et
on lui donnera la réponse évidemment la
plus adaptée mais c'est vrai pour les
magistrat administratif qui sont
embolisés il faut simplifier les
procédures on passe de 13 à 3 donc il y
a beaucoup de choses dans ce texte mais
je crois que ce qu'il faut retenir de ce
texte c'est qui donne une cohérence à
l'ensemble on va revenir dans dans le
détail he sur ce que contient cette loi
immigration mais sur ce qui s'est passé
hier est-ce que c'est un problème que le
rassemblement national a voté le texte
en revendiquant une victoire idéologique
il
faut cesser de se laisser influencé par
le Front national ils essayent de faire
un hold up ils ont contesté ce ce texte
depuis le début en disant c'est pas bien
pas suffisant pas assez dur vraiment un
texte mol àon et puis quand les choses
se mettent en place finalement ils
essayent de voler la victoire si je puis
dire euh ce sont en commission mixte
paritaire puisque vous y étiez ils l'ont
contesté ou ils l'ont soutenu pour
certains points ils ont soutenu d'autres
ils ont contesté par exemple sur
l'article 4 B qui est le métier en
tenstion ils l'ont contesté ce sont des
fbustiers des flibustiers de la
politique euh ils essayent d'en tirer un
profit personnel mais on n pas besoin
d'eux
on a pas besoin d'eux je crois qu'il
faut être assez clair nous ne partageons
pas les testes du Front national je ne
les partage pas pas plus que je ne
partage les tè de l'extrême gauche nous
avons notre texte notre stratégie nous
l'avons construite j'allais presque dire
évidemment le Sénat a été très influent
bien sûr mais nous avons discuté pour la
CMP avec le gouvernement et avec la
majorité présidentielle on a obtenu
quelque chose donc estce que là elle a
réussi un coup politique Marine Le Pen
elle essaie de réussir un coup politique
elle elle peut éventuellement le gagner
mais il faut vraiment le
combattre c'est pas son texte c'est
c'est une posture en tous les cas elle
fait de l'opportunisme politique c'est
tout ce que je ai en politique
d'ailleurs elle c'est ça son sujet donc
ne nous laissons pas influencer par
finalement ce parti politique qui ne vit
que sur les problématiques des autres
mais qui n'apporte jamais de solution
c'est en permanence un refus d'obstacle
donc neous laissons pas influencer par
elle ce texte il a divisé la majorité
chaouier votre homologue de l'Assemblée
nationale qui préside la commission des
lois a voté contre ce texte alors qu'il
était président de la commission mix
paritaire vous comprenez ce choix c'est
un choix qui lui est personnel on sait
que depuis longtemps il n'est pas
favorable c'est un homme de gauche pour
ne pas dire très à gauche euh à la
limite je respecte ses convictions bien
sûr que je les respecte ses convictions
mais c'est il avait laissé entendre en
commission mix paréire qui s'opposerait
à sec non non non non non non je
travaillerai aucun secret non pas du
tout on a eu la pilotter comme on pilote
habituellement la la commission mixte
paritaire donc il y avait pas de
surprise de ce point de vue là mais on
sait bien quelles sont ses convictions
faut pas se poser trop de questions faut
les respecter il a fait son choix
euhp il a pas voté l'accord du coup il
n'a pas pas voté il aurait pu peut-être
se déporter à la circonstance bon voilà
il faut respecter les convictions des
uns et des autres malgré tout ça a été
serré en commission mixte paréire le
vote euh non il était assez classique
hein c'est un vote assez classique av
une majorité assez large pour voter le
texte donc il y a pas eu de de problème
de ce point de vue là comment on va on
va venir à la CMP mais juste un un
dernier mot sur ce qui s'est passé cette
nuit puisque hier soir il y a des
ministres qui ont menacé de démissionner
Aurélien Rousseau le ministre de la
Santé lui a a présenté sa démission dans
la nuit après le vote parce que il juge
que le texte est trop droitisé et que
l'app des voix du RN ça n'allait pas
est-ce que vous comprenez là aussi cette
décision et est-ce qu'on rentre dans une
crise gouvernementale euh c'est la
jurisprudence Jean-Pierre chevenem
vous êtes d'accord et ben vous ne dites
rien je le dis poliment cétait pas sa
formule vous n'êtes pas d'accord ben
vous quittez bah là min ça ferme sa
gueule ou sa démissionne exactement à
partir du moment où le ministre de la
santé n'est pas d'accord il donne sa
démission mais il s'en va si c'est
uniquement donner sa démission pour
faire semblant de ça c'est parfaitement
contestable mais s'il décide de partir
ben il décide de partir voilà puis
terminer on en parlera plus mais mais
c'est son choix personnel mais une fois
de plus c'est un choix qu'il faut
respecter hein moi j' pas de conclusion
attive simplement il faut pas que ce
soit une forme de manipulation alors
après que vous qui vous donne
l'impression d'être local de la part de
l'il gauche de la majorité on verra on
verra aujourd'hui on verra la suite qui
sera donné à tout cela euh vous savez
c'est assez facile de brandir je après
moi le déluge je quitte tout je m'en
vais et puis au bout d'un rendez-vous
d'un quart d'heure on a changé ses
convictions si en revanche monsieur
Rousseau va au bout bah très bien c'est
son choix après est-ce qu'il y a une
crise euh c'est votre question en tous
les cas s'il y a pas une crise il y a un
moment de tension assez fort mais je le
redis la majorité du Renaissance a voté
largement le texte donc est en accord
avec ce qu'avait proposé le gouvernement
le ministre la première ministre et
finalement le président de la République
il a manqué 37 VO il a manqué 37 voix
oui bon ben voilà on sait que un texte
sur l'immigration qui est un texte
extrêmement difficile tout le monde sait
très bien qu'on ne s'occupe pas de colis
on s'occupe de personne c'est un sujet
très compliqué on ne peut pas faire
l'unanimité sur les choses comme ça
est-ce que euh vous y avez pensé en CMP
à force de droitiser le texte vous
saviez que ça risquait de casser du côté
de la majorité quand on négocie bien sûr
on on on respecte les uns et les autres
chacun fait un un pas en avant chacun
essaie de trouver une solution on a
toujours en tête c'est l'idée que on
défend toujours l'idée qu' il faut que
ça passe dans son camp d'ailleurs hier
le président du groupe chez nous est
revenu hier matin pour évoquer devant le
groupe un point particulier pour être
validé ça me paraît parfaitement
normal oui c'est le jeu c'est le jeu
c'est le jeu démocratique il faut le
respecter il a été difficile à obtenir
cet accord en commission mixte paritaire
il a été difficile à obtenir oui sur un
de points oui ce fut ce fut compliqué ce
fut il y avait la volonté d'aboutir
malgré tout disons les quelles sont CT
je le crois oui enfin en tout les cas
pour nous il y avait une volonté
d'aboutir sur la base de de quand vous
dites vous c'est uniquement la droite
sénatoriale ou c'est tous les LR où il y
avait
des différences de stratégie il il y a
pu y avoir à un moment des petites
différences de stratégie bien sûr mais
au bout du compte tout le monde vouleit
un texte pourquoi pas spécialement pour
embêter l'autre c'est pas ça le sujet
mais parce que le pays en a besoin quand
vous avez la population aujourd'hui qui
à travers les sondages même s'il faut
être prudent sur les sondages dit que le
sujet migratoire est un problème qui a
des inquiétudes qui en veul le moins on
est aussi élu on a des mandats et donc
il faut quand même se dire qu'on est
responsable de ça et moi je suis
convaincu que le fait d'avoir mis en
place pass une stratégie migratoire pour
le pays est une bonne chose et qu'il
c'était une opportunité j'allais dire
pour le coup de circonstances et
politique de pouvoir faire avancer les
choses il fallait la saisir mais est-ce
qu'il y avait plus du côté de la droite
sénatoriale une volonté de faire avancer
les choses et d'être constructif que du
côté d'Éric chier et d'Olivier marlex
pour être clair je je ne crois ah bah il
y avait une volonté peut-être peut-être
oui pour des raisons de circonstance
purement vous AES plus de politique
politicienne que vous ou oui le Sénat
est moins politicien
parfois un peu plus technique mais mais
bon au bout du compte c'est qu'on y
arrive et finalement tout le monde est
resté c'est normal il y a des il y a des
différences si ce n des différences tous
les cas des sensibilités un peu
différentes donc il faut que tout le
monde rentre dans le système pour que ça
marche mais ça c'est le jeu normal de
toute vie publique et de toute vie
collective dans un parti n'importe
quelle association c'est comme ça mais
c'est le sel est-ce que ça a été aussi
tendu avec vos alliés sans triste écoute
on a l'impression que Marseille éta un
petit peu agacé lundi
soir oui lundi soir parce que c'était un
peu c'était compliqué mais mais moi je
voudrais saluer Hervé Marseille et et et
le rapporteur Philippe boncarer et et
tous les collection tristes qui ont été
nous avons été ensemble nous avons été
des partenaires loyaux à par vraiment
vraiment faut le saluer c'était ça a été
en tous les cas pour moi qui préside la
commission et qui suivait vous comprenez
bien ce texte de très très près pour
plein de raisons je dois saluer ce ce
moment d'unité de la majorité
sénatoriale alors pencher sur le fond du
texte on va voir ce que contient
l'accord que vous avez trouvé et donc ce
qui est devenu maintenant cette loi
immigration on VO ça avec notre
journaliste Steve
[Musique]
Jourdin bonjour St bonjouran bonjour
monsieur le sénateur bonjour et Steve
que contient donc ce texte immigration
le texte immigration donc l'accord
conclu en CMP et donc validé par le
Parlement bah il est pas très loin de la
version que vous avez adopté ici au
Sénat mi-novembre c'est normal la base
discussion entre députés et sénateurs
depuis lundi était précisément ce texte
adopté à la Chambre haute alors on va
voir cette photo qui résume plutôt bien
l'état d'esprit post CMP cette photo
postée par la députée Annie jeunevard et
sa bande hein je pense qu'on peut on
peut dire ça comme ça je vais vous faire
le sous-texte victoire de la droite
victoire des sénateurs voilà donc pour
l'après CMP on va rentrer dans le détail
peut-être des mesures avec cette mesure
qui a provoqué un psychodrame ces
dernières heures ces derniers jours avec
la question des aPL les aides
personnalisées au logement le texte voté
par le Sénat et étudié par la CMP
prévoyait d'allonger à 5 ans de présence
sur le territoire le délai nécessaire
pour que les étrangers en situation
régulière puissent toucher les
allocations sociales 5 ans contre 6 mois
actuellement c'est ce qui exigeent les
sénateurs c'est ce qu'ils ont obtenu
euh avec cette CMP donc validé par le
Parlement l'accord prévoit donc que le
bénéfice des aPL sera désormais
conditionné à 5 de résidence stable et
régulière pour l'étranger qui ne
travaille pas et à 3 mois pour celui qui
travaille ces restrictions ne
s'appliquent pas aux réfugiés ni aux
étudiants étrangers Oran St quels sont
les autres points de cet accord entre
députés etén moins de régularisation
plus d'expulsion moins d'aide sociale
pour les étrangers on va voir un peu le
le détail de ces mesures le texte
prévoit des régularisations au cas par
cas pour les S papiers un titre de
séjour d'un an sera délivré à condition
d'avoir résidé en France pendant au
moins 3 ans et avoir exercé une activité
salariée durant au moins 12 mois sur les
deux dernières années les préfets diront
si oui ou non l'étranger en question
remplit ses conditions le texteé prévoit
aussi le rétablissement du délai de
séjour irrégulier supprimé sous François
Hollande l'encadrement plus strict de
l'immigration étudiante une caution sera
exigée de la part des étudiants
étrangers les frais d'inscription à
l'université seront aussi majorés il y a
également un durcissement des conditions
du regroupement familial la durée de
séjour minimal de l'étranger demandeur
est porté à 24 mois il devrait aussi
justifier de ressources financières
stables et si a également des mesures
concernant l'accès à la nationalité oui
les élus se sont aussi mis d'accord sur
les mesures pour durcir l'obtention de
la citoyenneté le texte prévoit la
déchéance de la de la déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux
coupables d'homicide volontaires sur des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique ou encore le durcissement des
conditions d'acquisition de la
nationalité par le droit du sol ça les
enfants de parents étrangers nés sur le
sol français aujourd'hui les parents
peuvent faire la demande à partir des 13
ans de l'enfant si celui-ci réside en
France depuis ses 8 ans Doren avant
c'est l'enfant lui-même qui entre ses 16
et 18 ans devra manifester sa volonté de
devenir Français monsieur le sénateur
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
vous accusent d'avoir repris les idées
de Jean-Marie Le Pen sur ce dernier
point il faut indiquer que la démarche
doit être volontaire c'est-à-dire que si
le mineur Demande la nation naalité elle
est plein droit h il faut préciser les
choses c'est très intéressant ce que
vous montrez mais il y a des points de
détails qu'il faudrait préciser pour nos
auditeurs écoutez c'est un faux argument
évidemment ça fait partie du
holdop mis en
place nous travaillons dans cette maison
depuis longtemps sur
l'immigration toutes ces mesures ne
viennent pas de nulle part ça fait
pratiquement depuis 2006 que je m'occupe
de ce sujetl nous avons à plusieurs
reprises proposé des mesures de cette
nature dans les textes qui ont toujours
été refusé par les gouvernements qui ont
été en place en tous les cas après 2011
et l'occasion a fait que cette fois-ci
on pouvait arriver à faire prospérer ses
idées mais au-delà de tout ça c'est quoi
le sujet c'est ce que je il y a quelques
instants c'est la volonté de choisir son
immigration et de mettre en place une
stratégie cette stratégie je le redis
c'est moins d'immigration régulière on
est à plus de 275000 presque 300000
personnes par an pour revenir à un éage
beaucoup plus bas sur le fait d'avoir
une immigration économique qualifiée et
puis c'est de fixer c'est de fixer les
conditions de séjour sur le territoire
national français avec les mesures que
vous venez d'évoquer quand excusez-moi
monsieur sénateur mais quand vous
conditionner les allocations sociales à
un certain nombre d'années de présence
sur le territoire est-ce que c'est pas
de la préférence nationale est-ce que
c'est pas des idées fa d' je le il faut
d'abord raer qu'il s'agit des
prestations sociales non contributive
c'est ce qui explique d'ailleurs que
pour les étrangers sur le territoire
national qui ne travaillent pas qui ne
travaillent pas il y a ce délai de 5 ans
qui a été appliqué mais ça a été tout
l'objet de la discussion pour ceux qui
travaillent et le délai de carence qui a
été établi et de 3 mois c'est un délai
parfaitement raisonnable qui permet
ensuite à la personne d'en
bénéficier de bénéficier paremp de laap
parce que ça ne concerne pour le coup
que laap pas les autres mesures que laap
donc sinon les autres mesures disz quand
même entre et bien les Français et les
étrangers mais quand vous allez dans un
pays à l'étranger vous ne bénéficiez pas
forcément de toutes les règles possibles
sur le pays dans le pays où vous allez
il y a d'autres mesures qui sont qui
sont déjà en place en France sur les Ch
de cette nature je pense notamment à
l'ASPA qui est l'aide pour les personnes
âgées c'est 10 ans pour l'obtenir donc
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau c'est
simplement le fait de dire quand on ne
contribue pas par son activité
professionnelle
à la vie du
pays on ne peut pas bénéficier
immédiatement je on bénéficiera mais on
ne peut pas bénéficier immédiatement de
la solidarité nationale qui a les
contributive vous récusez ce vous
récusez ce terme de préférence nationale
bien sûr que je récuse ce terme de
préférence nationale et puis l'enjeu du
texte au bout du compte c'est quoi c'est
de dire que lorsque l'étranger arrive
sur le territoire national qui respecte
l'ensemble de ses règles et qu'il est
dans le le jeu de de de la France en
fait et ben il devient il rentre dans la
communauté nationale comme tout le monde
il vit sa vie et on lui fiche la pai moi
l'objectif que je poursuivais c'est
qu'au moment où quelqu'un fait une
demande pour venir sur le territoire
national la préfecture étudie sa
situation dans son ensemble euh on lui
demande les conditions qu'on fixe il les
respecte il rentre on après on lui fiche
la paix il vit sa vie sur le territoire
national il est partage l'enjeu qui est
le nôtre et et et tout ça est parfait
évidemment que l'étranger qui commet un
crime euh et ben évidemment c'est pas
possible il peut pas rester sur il y a
aussi la fin de l'automaticité du droit
du sol c'est un tournant que certains
qualifient d'historique vous récusez là
encore c'est pas la fin l'automaticité
ce qu'on a évoqué c'est le fait que le
mineur doit être doit faire une démarche
oui je veux devenir français c'est pas
c'est pas rien c'est dire on n pas au
guichet de la poste où on retire un
timbre et on a tout de suite son truc
c'est le fait devenir français ça doit
avoir un sens ça c'est fondamental nous
avons des valeurs vous avez des valeurs
nous nous respectons nos valeurs
républicaines nous y sommes attachés et
et donc si moi je veux devenir français
je suis étranger je veux devenir
français c'est parce que je partage ces
valeurs et j'ai envie de faire partie de
la communauté nationale au sens large du
terme c'est pas une petite affaire c'est
vraiment un engagement si demain je vais
habiter dans un pays étranger et je dis
mais je veux prendre la nationalité de
ce pays je conçois parfaitement qu'on me
dise mais est-ce que vous partagez ce
que nous sommes notre mode de vie notre
façon d'être les valeurs de notre pays
et c'est parfaitement les légitime il y
a eu aussi cette sortie hier plutôt
originale de de géralde dermanin ici au
Sénat qui qui disait qu'il y avait
certaines mesures dans ce texte qui
n'était pas forcément très
constitutionnel quel est votre avis làus
oui oui benah on partage il y a quelques
sujet sur lequel il y a des
interrogations mais le sa on sait que le
Conseil constitutionnel va être saisi
bien il appréciera mais quelle mesure en
particulier vous avez en tête non parce
que je veux pas je pas entrer dans le
détail voulez pas influencer le Conseil
consti surt pas une peti idée vousz une
idée mais bien sûr qu'on a une idée mais
euh il est aussi normal qu' un moment la
représentation nationale telle qu'elle
est puisse dire voilà sur tel sujet
voilà l'objectif après on a essayé on a
équilibré les choses le plus possible et
le Conseil constitutionnel qui est la
juridiction qui surveillera ces chosesl
bah fera son travail et et on se
soumettra à ce que dira le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est pas la question
mais il y a aussi à un moment des
messages envoyés donc a certaines
mesures sont des messages politiques
comment certaines mesures dans ce texte
sont des messages politiques non mais il
y a des objectifs techniques très réels
mais il y a aussi des messages à envoyer
dans cette matière là en matière
d'immigration j'en termine par
là la règle est très importante
évidemment mais le message envoyé est
très important aussi et en particulier à
l'égard des réseaux mafieux j'insiste
beaucoup là-dessus parce que c'est
fondamentalement le problème qui profite
de la misère du monde pour faire venir
ir sur le territoire national des gens
qui se retrouvent dans de très grandes
difficultés ici et c'est ces réseau là
qui à qui il faut dire écoutez la règle
du jeu change aujourd'hui voilà les
conditions pour venir en France et et si
vous respectez ces conditions là mais
c'est bienvenu bien évidemment
ellisabeth B s'est engagée à faire une
réforme de l'aide médicale d'État au
début de l'année he ça faisait partie
des points de la négociation quelle
réforme vous souhaitez est-ce que vous
voulez revenir à l'AMU l'aide médicale
d'urgence strict au cinsus vous avez
voté ou vous êtes prêts à autre chose je
crois qu'il faut accepter comme tout
sujet de poser tous les problèmes sur la
table euh nous pensons qu'il faut revoir
laame telle qu'elle existe ne pas la
supprimer mais la revoir il y a un
rapport qui a été rendu euh de Patrick
stéphanini et de Monsieur evvin et ce
rapport il est assez éloquent pour ceux
qui ça intéresse alleer voir l'article
la page 53 de mémoire mais sur ce base
de ce travail il faut avancer donc il
faut mieux organiser les choses mieux
circonscrire les opérations de façon à
ce que laame remplisse vraiment son rôle
ne soit pas détourné de sa fonction moi
je pense qu'un sujet majeur c'est le
fait de contrôler en fait du contrôle de
l'attribution de laame mais ensuite du
contrôle de la situation de l'étranger
qui est en situation irrégulière je le
redis bien c'est pour des étrangers en
situation irrégulière donc il faut
regarder ça avec beaucoup de sérénité et
accepter de les constats du rapport sont
sont présents sont utiles mais voilà
mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut revoir parce
que Gérald armmanin il dit que c'est pas
le panier de soin le problème c'est le
statut alors il il y a les deux il y a
un peu le panier de soin quand même et
puis il y a effectivement le statut
qu'il faut reprendre avec le contrôle du
statut moi je partage ce point de vue
mais posons le débat il faut à tout prix
j'allais presque dire déstresser tout le
monde sur le sujet hein euh il est pas
question de pas soigner non plus
l'urgence vitale elle doit être soignée
bien évidemment tout ce qui concerne les
risques de pardon non non les tout ce
qui concerne les risques d'épidémie
quelqu'un qui est malade qui aura la
tuberculose on soigne bien évidemment
c'est ça il a a pas fait une erreur
d'appeler ça médicale d'urgence est-ce
que ça a envoyé un mauvais signal on
aura peut-être dû l'expliquer un peu
différemment être plus précis on n'est
jamais parfait naturellement mais à
partir du moment où il y aura un projet
de loi spécifique là-dessus c'est
l'engagement qui a été pris auprès du
présidents du Sénat posons le problème
et réglons les problèmes moi je il faut
apaiser quand même tout ça ça part dans
des conditions d'hystérisation un peu
généralisée il est temps de se que les
choses se calment qu'on et qu'on essaie
de faire continuer de faire avancer les
choses sereinement il y a pas
de c'est une nécessité pour le pays
c'est incontestable mais il y a aussi du
respect à l'égard des migrants mais
c'est parfaitement normal c'est logique
sur la révision de la Constitution oui
c'est pour quand c'est votre prochaine
demande sujet vouszcoup de sujet sur
l'immigration vous demandez toujours une
réforme de la Constitution Emmanuel
Macron a refermé la portière oui j'ai vu
que le président a dit
non on avait un texte ici qui a été
dénaturé en tous les cas qui n'a pas qui
n'a pas passé le cap de la commission
des lois disons les choses telles
qu'elles sont euh il peut y avoir alors
le président de la République il veut
modifier l'article 11 il le dit à
Saint-Denis après la réunion d'après il
veut plus on a quand même un petit sujet
constitutionnel sur lequel il faudra
regarder pour préserver certains
éléments de souveraineté il faud une
urgence aujourd'hui à réformer la
Constitution sur ce sujet d'immigration
après cette loi surtout eu une urgence
en tous les cas nessayer de reposer le
texte de revoir les mesures qu'on peut
améliorer on va attendre la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel mais oui il faut
qu'il faut travailler sereinement sur ce
sujet là vous saz c'est possible
sereinement quand on voit ce qui se
passe à l'Assemblée nationale quand on
voit après il a des questions de timing
c'est peut-être pas immédiatement qu'il
faut faire ça faut peut-être le faire en
cours d'année ça prendra du temps on ne
modifie pas la Constitution comme ça en
2 minutes en toutous les cas moi je suis
hosyle on fait les choses sérieusement
voilà on va sans doute redéposer un
texte mais enfin pour pas immédiatement
tout de suite est-ce qu'il faut revoir
l'accord FrancoAlgérien de 68 qui
accorde un statut favorable au
ressortissant alors je vous informe que
euh dans quelques minutes je vais avoir
une réunion de bureau de la commission
des Loir et que nous allons proposer je
vais proposer euh bah avec Philippe
boncarer que on a vu en photo tout à
l'heure l'idée de faire un point sur
l'ensemble des conventions qui lit la
France avec les pays étrangers dont la
convention qui nous lie avec l'Algérie
on a besoin d'un état des lieuux une
fois de plus je ne veux pas procéder
dans une urgence absolue parce que ça
n'a pas de sens mais on va faire un état
lieu complet de ces conventions et
singulièrement sur le traité qui nous l
acgérie pour voir comment choses peuvent
évoluer en fait dans ce traité là il y a
plusieurs sujets je pas rentrer dans le
détail il y a un sujet sur ce qu'on
appelle il y a les avantages entre
guillemets sociaux et les avantages qui
sont liés ou les régimes particuliers
qui sont liés aux conditions d'arriver
sur le territoire donc c'est il faut
reposer à les choses il faut le remettre
à PL faut le remettre à plat oui oui
parce que pourquoi il faut le remettre à
plat c'est pas un dogme absolu dire il
faut le remettre à plat vous rendez
compte on a une convention spécifique
depuis 1970 avec l'Algérie très bien une
fois qu'on a dit ça on a égité un peu
les choses mais aujourd'hui cette
convention elle avait eu lieu à un
moment où au moment de l'indépendance de
l'Algérie et on a on a traité les
conditions de cette indépendance après
sentant d'histoire commune on sait que
c'est
sensible et donc il est normal aussi que
maintenant que l'indépendance est
acquise depuis bien longtemps et que
tout ça se retrouve dans les relations
parfaitement normales donc on pose le
problème on n'en fait pas un drame
absolu ça ne sert à rien en revanche si
on veut faire avancer les choses on n
fait pas un drame absolu hein un dernier
mot Emmanuel Macron va prendre la parole
ce soir et sera peut-être c'est à vous
sur France 5 qu'est-ce que vous attendez
du chef de l'État et ben je sais pas
très franchement je ne sais pas parce
que euh je m'interroge sur cette
intervention après le vote de ce texte
euh on va attendre mais dans la vie
normale si je puis dire le texte était
voté il y aura probablement c'est du
Conseil constitutionnel il faut rester
serein merci on a besoin de sérénité sur
tous les sujets dans ce monde politique
merci frananel buffet Ston merci à vous